Favorite moment filming
Season 2, and why.
Let's start with you, Joey.
Favorite moment, crumbs!
Um, I think it was
probably actually...
what sticks in my mind
is my first day of shooting
after the pandemic.
Just coming back,
and I was...
we were halfway up a mountain
in the Lake District,
and it was just
the first time that...
I guess you guys had done
a bit of shooting
before the hiatus,
and then I was sitting
around in my room
for six, eight months,
and I don't know,
it was a really--
it was a complicated scene,
and there was
an awful lot of dialogue,
and I was just
freezing my pants off
in a lake in the middle
of January, whenever it was.
Looking ripped!
Is that all you did,
sit-ups the whole time?
I just didn't eat.
It's not that hard, uh...
But yeah, that was
really, really fun,
'cause it was the first time
I'd seen you in a while,
and it just felt like
coming home again, you know?
Just all the pals,
all your friends and colleagues
that you've not seen in so long.
It just... yeah, that stayed
with me for a while.
It was so wonderful.
Anya, what was your
favorite moment?
Um, my favorite moment was
probably the aqueducts.
I loved working with
the team that I did--
Eamon, Kevin, Jamal,
it was a really special scene.
-Freya?
-Um, I would just say
all the times when it was
me with all the Witchers.
Like, I just... I just found
that dynamic so funny.
Like, me amongst all these,
like, 6-foot-2 men.
Just, like, little me
in a white dress.
There's just, like,
something about it
which was hysterical,
and so,
I felt like
I could just tease them all,
'cause I was in that sort of--
I don't know.
They were like
my older brothers,
all of them.
Yeah. And it really called back
to that Knucklebones scene
we see, like, in the very,
very beginning of Season 1.
You really have come
your tomboy way.
Yeah, exactly.
And Henry,
what was your favorite scene?
Um, it's--I mean,
tough to say favorite scene,
to be honest.
Tough to say favorite moment.
But I think
my favorite moment...
or my favorite time was
during the Lake District.
It was so stunning up there.
It just felt like a hobbit
was gonna walk around the corner
every five seconds.
And, in a good way.
I loved it up there.
I love location work,
and I feel you can really draw
from the environment around you,
and we're in
a  fantasyshow like this,
and you can really
transport yourself there,
especially if
you're looking that way
and all you have is
another character in costume
and you can't see
the camera crew or anything,
and you're saying,
"I'm here.
I'm existing within it."
And that stuff is extraordinary.
Like what you see?
Be sure to check out
the full episode
of The Witcher: Unlocked,
the official Netflix Geeked
aftershow.